what's up reject nation greg here aaron
here
i'm excited to be doing this umbrella
academy season two
love the show love it so i'm very
excited for season two
this is gonna be reaction highlights if
you follow me on twitter you'll see that
like i've talked with a whole bunch of
reactors especially ones who do tv show
reactions so
gonna be following their rule of thumb
to at least get this video visible on
youtube from my understanding gonna be
near impossible to get this video like
monetized i'm just trying not to get it
blocked worldwide
my goal is to try to get one of these up
every other day so subscribe and click
that notification bell so you get
notified when we got another one of
these reactions up on youtube with that
in mind i
i do want to give a sincere thank you to
everyone who has gone and shown their
support for the real rejects over at our
patreon because over there we do a
weekly q a podcast and then we do a
bunch of tv show reaction watch alongs
many of those shows have reaction
highlights included and those shows are
supernatural doctor who jojo's bizarre
adventure the promised neverland
attack on titan death note my hero
academia code geass hunter hunter full
metal alchemist brotherhood violet
evergarden demon slayer
one punch man and then there are other
shows rio do only
watch alongs for them there's a whole
bunch of them as well and john actually
does music video reactions like two to
three times a week
sometimes i join him load if you could
go show your support over at our patreon
page today it's a whole lot of fun it's
like a second channel in so many ways
channel number two aaron thanks for
being here follow him on instagram
let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
the the 60s
yep no black people oh
this classic guy poor guy
oh god getting all the stairs no he's a
ghost okay he's safe this feels very
back to the future
you guys knew you were time traveling
didn't you oh 61.
oh oh damn they're being spread out
that's awesome by yourself they're
landing in the same spot
each year wow why are they really young
in the same spot
this actor has a lot of pressure to stay
the same age yeah
i wonder if they're gonna hit chapter
two him with some [ __ ] makeup did
this say where he landed did i miss that
i think he said
oh [ __ ] there it is there it is oh what
the hell
oh no oh
[ __ ] oh why
is she a [ __ ] superhero holy [ __ ]
what dude
[Music]
oh [ __ ] that's the army of the dead hell
yeah
60s avengers baby let's go
yes the hair oh hell yeah
oh umbrella academy
[ __ ] what ben
damn that's vicious it's amazing it's
beautiful
they're the x-men they're basically that
oh oh
diego
wow
i know what it's like to be stuck in
time
thinking this is how you're going to
live out the rest of your life wow this
is really like five show huh
five shows at once
[Laughter]
i don't give a [ __ ] oh dude
luther luther what happened to you
oh god damn it that's great i want more
that was great that was that was that
was genuinely
fuzz
[Music]
solid first episode i mean for a season
one episode that is pretty incredible
stuff one thing that really dawned on me
as the episode was wrapping up generally
between seasons i actually
tend to get pretty annoyed when there's
like a time jump usually you know time
jump forward
in most cases with shows and then all
our characters are like
completely different and we miss the
journey
and i'm like why are they just so
different you know and we miss out all
the fun
with that and this is the case of oh
this is how you do it properly this is
how you do it in a way
where it works within the context of the
show the context of the story like
everyone is different
yeah it's still interesting yeah yeah
it's not like what the hell it's more
like it's
it's intriguing with knowing the way
with the time travel and how all that
works uh how that's built into the dna
of
umbrella academy it makes it that much
more mysterious
i learned about all the characters from
season one already and i didn't
like everyone at first but eventually i
grew to love everyone what they've done
with all them here
i i i'm like yeah this is they're all
cool
and it's it's it really hit me in this
one too that this is five's
show basically you know and it's like
the the linchpin that holds the plot
together
exactly and what i love about that is
the reversal of how
he was missing in the first season he
comes back and he's this guy who was
just
lost for decades not in their timeline
but in his timeline those like years he
became an old man and
time traveled through world and stuff
because of his experiences with that
he's the one who can truly help unite
them and also
a lot of this is his fault of why
they're stuck here
he's he's the nick fury of season two
yeah yet it seems like he doesn't have
any like
guilt towards the situation yeah he had
no choice
right right yeah he had to save her
siblings yeah
so he can't doesn't have to beat himself
up about
it i like how he's trying to do it but
he's like so nonchalant like doesn't
really care at the same time
you gotta do it because like we're gonna
we gotta save the world again he's like
again
damn it damn it they did a good job at
catching us up with all the characters
or where they're at in this new section
of the show
but it also felt like it was mainly for
this particular episode
diego's episode diego n5 it's like you
spent time with everyone pretty much
uh more than just one time in the show
diego was like the main driving force
yeah if anyone's had
probably the biggest reintroduction it's
diego yeah
like it seems like he's been through a
lot in 75 days you know being in the
psych ward you know
all like caveman looking and whatnot you
know it's kind of sarah connor from
terminator 2. yeah totally the thing i
love about this season so far is like
you can tell like the little influences
from each sort of
sci-fi narrative they take from taking
brought a little bit from back to the
feature a little bit from terminator
hazel back in the
beginning of the episode and he was like
come with me if you want to yeah
straight up arnold
is awesome i added you really latch onto
that part how did i not lie down to that
i mean i wonder if they're going to do
something with hazel to bring him back
because that's the thing with this show
is with the way time travel works and
the fact that like they've survived
like they they have that badass
introduction and we're right hell have
you been five minutes yeah dude they're
like
the freaking x-men of them wiped out
again
immediately great setup right there and
also the tease of like
the the path of redemption for vania's
character yeah
you know they are going with like the
classic lost my memory thing whoopsie
daisy but i'm like let's see how it
plays out like they've been there done
that but like i like the way they're
going
seemingly kind of give her a semi-happy
life i mean let's see how it plays out
but i'm also curious if she is lying
yeah that's true because we only have
her interactions with this one other
woman and her douchey
probably cheating husband i mean she's
going to be a cheating wife
that's very true but they're obviously
obviously going to bang right like
just honestly just it's kind of obvious
yeah
luther got lean he got look his makeup
looks a lot better this season
there was something about the i know
that it's supposed to have this shock
look of like it's supposed to look
disproportionate and
feel strange but there was something
about in the first season that whenever
i looked at it it looked like a bodysuit
yeah it looked awkward it looked like
makeup yeah and
um i think the actor's great but the
makeup on it
was wasn't bad it just the way they
captured it and maybe
in some areas of where it was bulked up
didn't look like a human anatomy
deformation in a natural sense
it looked like a bodysuit and then here
i'm like whoa this looks very
natural you know what i think it was i
think because they were trying to
do things that were influenced by the
comics you're trying to make their
homage and
in the comics you had a human head but
like a straight up blue ape body
and then okay yeah yeah so in season two
like we gotta kind of make it look like
that but
as they went on like this doesn't look
too great so they kind of lean them out
for season two which looks a lot better
for the show i mean it looks like that
could actually be his weird hairy 8-band
body
i mean and also like beyond like the
technical aesthetic yeah it's all great
like the production design of it is
still wonderful the musical choices
everything feels very fluid the
transitions there was something
in the f what i felt like in the first
few episodes of umbrella academy season
one was that it seemed like it was still
trying to find its pacing
and try to find its voice right tonally
and how to smooth through all these
different because every every character
lends itself to a different tone here
with the different setups for all these
people you know you got
allison who's married active in the
civil rights movement you got klaus and
ben
who who kind of simpler where they'd be
where they're at
you know like i love i love a couple of
things so far in this season i love the
fact that when you first go to the 60s
it makes sense that
they'd address the segregation thing
because usually when you have like you
deal with time travel when you have a
black character they never really
address it because of like it stunts
they're they're storytelling but
they're taking it head-on in this season
and it makes sense that she'd marry a
black man
considering if she were to marry a white
dude in this universe she'd probably get
like a lot of eyes also the thing with
with ben and klaus the fact that they've
kind of
embraced that that kind of duo they got
going looks like ben has a little bit
more of a role
going this forward in this season he
didn't really talk a lot in the first
season at least the second half or the
first half well he didn't but it also
seems like that klaus
has been able to utilize his powers now
yeah like he's learned how to embrace it
even in
just properly communicating with ben the
fact that they can physically touch each
other and the way they
they wrestled and rustled and tussled
wrestled and tussle russell yeah
absolutely russell yeah the way they
they never do it
the way they did like they're used to
touching each other because you even
notice it when they come out of the car
like oh yeah he did he did just open the
door
ben's learned his powers yeah like is
that how that works okay i'll go with it
it's a door
yeah their scenario is exactly what you
would imagine they would be in
it seems like klaus is just influenced
so much by whatever time he's in like
he gets dropped into vietnam war like
all right i'm here
i'm going to be a soldier yeah and then
here the sixes oh be a hippie
it just embraces whatever it is i feel
bad for the guy that's because
he tossed around like a ragdoll through
time oh speaking of which i
guess kind of a question from season one
did ben go with him to the i was
wondering that when i was watching the
show
yeah did he live through that again you
can tell that they have that kind of
brotherly
kind of bickering because ben doesn't
really have a choice yeah in the matter
he's kind of stuck with him and the fact
that he can kind of make him tangible
because he didn't go blue in this
episode
kind of indicates to me that maybe for
some reason
clout klaus hasn't been doing drugs yeah
at least as many drugs
maybe the kind of drugs the kind of
drugs he could be on
a lot of mushrooms because if yeah if
he's on shrooms i imagine that might
help a guy out with this kind of power
right yeah make it more creative also
the alien angle of them
yeah that's so fitting because the
teleportation thing makes me think of
terminator
but then for this time period uh aliens
ufos area
before that was becoming a real
repressed topic in the media
right because the the way with alien
invasions of how that's gone
especially with media reporting on it
was something that was very speculative
something that was a lot of sight scenes
and then the media was really shunning
and then now weirdly in the past year
the pentagon's like yep ufo sightings
this is legit guys it's real um
so to be at the time of repressing that
information and then
also them dealing with the consequences
of kennedy it's like everyone but diego
seems to be
on the train of we have to let it happen
right but i'm also thinking though
timeline is already so different the
fact that you've got
all these individuals who are here in
this timeline
in different spots you're you're messing
up the timeline you're already affected
i'm like
yeah might as well make the future what
you want to be at this point yeah
save the president yeah exactly i
remember in the first season
five was supposed to kill kennedy and he
didn't do it
yes did they settle on that it was lee
harvey oswald i don't remember either
way
diego trying to prevent it and then him
having a possible
love interest with with his potential
the other patient his baby mom
i love what diego's doing oh he's great
everyone was kind of
playing an archetype in the first season
and they did a great job at it some more
unique than others
but people like diego people like luther
they were
playing the archetype and then here it
seems
like they're going way against what
their art type was so immediately their
characters are actually much more
intriguing this time around yeah i think
the one that seems the most oh you know
he's kind of grown i was gonna say klaus
still seems kind of
kind of goofy but he would definitely
not kind of like the strung out and drug
he was in the first season
well yeah i mean class is always just
klaus is the most captivating character
to me a thousand percent which
which is funny because when in the first
couple episodes i thought it was very
annoying
really i loved it and then it became my
favorite character
yeah yeah him and five are my favorites
so much more to come
you know uh this was this is pretty
awesome the music is great
i can't wait to see what else is in
store the next nine episodes
and the way they're dealing with
historical fiction in this time period
i i love the backdrops are they're going
to see daddy hargraves yes that's my
biggest part we're going to see baby
pogo
low pogo no pogo
all right guys so what did you think of
this episode leave your thoughts down
below make sure to subscribe and click
that notification bell check us out on
patreon full length reaction
watch along over there has to really cut
this one up i haven't yet at the time of
filming this obviously
but i know i will have just look at it
scuba steve scuba steve now scuba steve
apparently he qualified for a shout out
last month i don't
think we gave you one so a i gotta say
scuba steve
i'm so sorry for doing that buddy
apologize scuba i'm really
really sorry so you're gonna have to get
two shout outs of one because john
forgot to write your name down john's
not here right now so i could blame him
always do that as scuba even for
yourself
just blame john it's an ongoing joke
where he just
suffers but it it's a really
great scapegoat anyway i feel like he's
the matt damon
to you
scuba steve uh
scuba steve i never want you to leave
if you did i would grieve trying to help
me out
please i like to rake leaves on my yard
yeah man you uh your first name might be
scuba
man i want to do you in the poopa and
have you
lick my saliva go down a pipe hit your
ass like king koopa
ooh very good the guy likes to spray
paint
sometimes he doesn't wear a mask and he
starts to faint
and i'll lick your taint
i cannot wait said scuba steve
because his horniness he will relieve
any day of the week go check out aaron's
poetry
on his instagram
you